The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Welcome to class.
The theme of today's lecture
is all about testing.
So I'm going to give the
intro to testing lecture
where I talk about testing
and how, what it is,
and why we do it.
Give you some
basic testing tips,
and let you know what we
expect you to be doing in terms
of testing for your projects.
And I'll spend a little
more time on focus testing,
because that's the part
people are frequently
least familiar with.
We have Genevieve
Conley from Riot,
and she's going to give a
lecture related to testing.
But more about what Riot's
doing and stuff like that.
So hopefully that will be fun.
We'll take a break.
And then since we just
told you all about testing
and how important it is, we will
go ahead and run a focus test
in class.
We'll give you some time
to get things set up,
probably about 10 minutes
to plan your test.
Then we'll set things up
and we will run testing.
We're going to ask that everyone
on your team test at least
two games and that
everyone on your team
observe at least one
person playing a game.
How exactly you're going to
make all of that happen in flow
is your problem.
And then we will come down.
We'll give you some time to let
your team compare observations
and talk about
results, and then we'll
ask you to come down for
a standard in class, two
minute no visuals presentation.
Monday, project two is due
along with your design change
log and focus test reports
and your individual write-ups,
and the project
two presentation.
This is a five
minute presentation.
There are presentation
guidelines on Stellar.
You can download
and look at them.
Once again, we're
primarily looking
for postmortem and reflection.
We want to hear
about your process.
We want to know
what you learned.
We want to know what you did
right, what you did wrong,
and what you're going
to do in the future.
And we want it in five minutes.
Grades for project one are
up, along with comments
about your individual
postmortems
and some comments about
the overall project stuff.
Overall, we were really
impressed with the quality
of project one.
So keep it up.
But do you stop and
read the comments
so that you guys
can make sure to do
good jobs on your individual
postmortems going forward.
Anything to add?
All right.
So people say testing.
People say quality assurance.
What are they?
Quality assurance is actually
just a whole process.
It involves a whole lot of
different types of testing.
But in general, it's
the systematic process
checking to see whether
a product of service
being developed is meeting
its specified requirements.
The most important
part of that definition
really is systemic,
which means you're doing
regular, repeatable testing.
Looking at making sure that
all the portions of your game
or project are working.
And requirements,
making sure you're
meeting that it
doesn't just "work"
as far as you think it does.
It works according the
requirements of the game,
of the project, of
whoever you're shipping
to and et cetera and so forth.
So you need to know what
your standards are to be
doing good quality assurance.
Without testing, your
project will fail,
and will take more time, and
will take a lot more effort.
You can make games
without programmers.
There's a lot of graphical user
interface engines out there.
Some of them are
getting older and older,
but they're out there
and you can use them.
GameMaker, for example.
You can make games
without artists.
I bet several of
you are figuring out
how to do that right now.
But you can also
make games completely
without assets using text
engines like Inform 7.
You don't really need designated
producer or distinct game
designer on a small team.
One person can
really do it alone.
But you're never going to make
a good game without testing,
and the more
systemic and planned
your testing is, the
more results you'll
get from less effort.
So who gets to do
all this testing?
That's really everyone
involved in the project.
Do not assume that
because you are
the key programmer
or the key designer
or the key whatever that someone
else will check your code
and make sure it's working
after you've integrated it.
You really want
everyone on the team
to consider it to be
their responsibility
to keep the game working
as well as possible
all the way through, and
also to take the time
to go in and check
other people's stuff
to make sure that it went in.
Remember that this is one of
the cornerstones of using Scrum
as well, where before a
task is actually done,
someone else has gone
in and verified it.
Well, someone else is going to
be someone on the team, which
means you're all going to have
allot some time to doing it,
and you're going to have
to think about that.
Speaking of which, anybody have
testing as one of your tasks
on your sprint task list?
Anybody?
Woo, you win.
It's going to take some time.
And it's going to take some
time that probably otherwise
could be used for making code.
So go ahead and
remember that now
and think about
that as you're going
into your last week
of work, that you need
to allot some time for testing.
So types of testing.
What is the
terminology I'm going
to use so that we all understand
what I'm saying when I say it?
I divide testing up
into three major areas,
and there isn't a lot of formal
methodology on this, especially
not in the game industry.
So I tend to talk about
technical testing, play
testing, and user testing.
When I say technical testing, I
mean getting your game to run.
Specifically, I often
mean getting your game
to run exactly as how
you intended it to run.
So if the designer claims that
the peach mobile should go up
to 30 miles per hour and fire
eight peaches per second,
if you go into the
game and you discover
that it goes 70 miles
per hour and fires
two peaches per
second, that's not
working even if it makes game
awfully fun with it like that.
When you start thinking
about whether it's fun or not
as a developer, then you're
moving into the area of play
testing which is
where you, the team,
are playing your game
trying to figure out,
hey, all those requirements and
constraints and plans we made,
are they working?
And are they working well, and
is a player going to enjoy it?
You're play testing your
game as a developer.
You're checking to
make sure it works.
In that case, yes.
The fact that the peach
mobile is currently
going 30 miles per hour and it's
so slow that no player is ever
going to want to use it.
That's a bug.
That's a really big bug.
But it's a play testing
bug if your specs say
it should be going
30 miles per hour,
not a technical testing bug.
And it is good to know the
differences so that you
can know what
you're talking about
and why you're talking about it.
Finally, there's
user testing, which
is getting someone who is not
on your team to play your game.
You, the developer, while
you do play testing,
can pretend to be
an actual player.
But you are not
You will never be an actual
player for your game.
You know it too well.
You are too close to it.
You have spent too
many hours playing it.
So you really need to
get someone who has never
seen your game before, ideally,
to come in and sit down
in front of your
game and play it.
We're going to make pretend
when we run our focus testing
workshop that your classmates
here are actually good testers.
Tell you a secret, they're not.
They've seen your game because
they've play tested it before.
They've heard you talk about it.
They heard you pitch it.
They might even have worked
on it if they switched teams.
So they're not actually
your ideal testers,
but they are very
convenient testers.
So we're going to
use them today.
And for your next
projects, we're
going to encourage
you-- and, in fact,
require you-- to go out
into the cold, cold world
and find actual testers
who haven't seen your game.
People in your dorms.
People in your other classes.
Friends, people at
the coffee shop.
Whoever you think will do
the best job of giving you
the information you need.
User testing is another
one of those terminologies
that means a whole lot.
So for my convenience,
I tend to divide it
up into two kinds of things,
focus testing and "user
testing."
Where "focus testing"
is specifically
when you're sitting down
and you're playing the game,
looking at how it plays.
Is it fun?
Are people enjoying it?
Is it challenging enough?
Are the mechanics interesting?
Is your game a good game, and
getting that information back
from your players.
When user testing,
I tend to use more
for looking at the
usability of your game.
You may have a really,
really fun game,
but if it takes your
players 12 minutes
to get off your starting page
because they can't figure out
what they're doing
or how to do it,
that's a pretty serious
usability issue.
And you need to figure
that out as well.
So just so you know that those
are those two user types.
It's all user
testing, but having
some granularity to find the
difference is a little useful.
So the basics for technical
testing, which hopefully we
can go through pretty quickly.
I suspect that if you guys
have done programming,
you've done this before.
If you've had classes that
wanted code that worked,
hopefully they've helped teach
you what the good things to do
are.
A lot of this sounds an
awful lot like good software
practices lecture
that Andrew gave,
because a lot of good testing
is, in fact, a good software
practice.
So have some
technical standards.
Have a bug database.
Or, given the size
of these projects,
at least a bug Excel spreadsheet
with a list of everything
that you've noticed.
Build and test before
checking it in.
Have daily builds.
Have a daily play-through.
Planned feature cuts.
Scope.
When you realize that you're
not getting everything
done on Friday night as
you're working on your game,
start cutting then.
Don't wait until
Sunday night to decide
what you're going to cut.
Cut as soon as you realize that
you're blowing your estimates.
That will allow you
to choose what you cut
and to adjust
changes in your game
to reflect the things you cut.
It will also mean
that testing your game
to make sure-- it will
introduce a lot fewer bugs
when you do it in a controlled
manner than when you do it
in desperation, which is
why I put it under testing.
Finally, code freezes
and asset freezes.
These are great,
and no one likes
to use them because
it means you're
going to waste an entire day
not working on your game.
Who wants to do that?
On the other hand, has anybody
here turned in a project
that they've made a last
minute change to Sunday night,
it was due Monday morning,
and then it didn't run at all?
I got some honest
people out there.
Good.
The advantage of taking that
whole day to test your game
is you turn something
in that works on Monday.
Often, you turn
in something that
works a lot better on
Monday because you've
taken the time to test it.
You've found the bugs.
You've had a friend help you
review your code changes,
and you really got it working.
If you want to make a
good, polished, solid game,
you will think about
it and give yourself
a cushion for project two.
That's probably maybe a day.
It's a two week project.
If you give yourself much
more cushion than that,
you're not actually
working on it.
But actively give
yourself that deadline
and give yourself some
time to play your game.
So that's the basics.
Some advanced tips.
It's all pretty simple.
I think you've all
heard this all.
How we maintain
your feature list.
Agree on how features
are going to work,
so talk with each other.
Test those features
as soon as they go in.
This may not be worth
it on these games,
because they're small.
When you hit your
project four game,
you may want to
have one of these.
Think about having a
standardized test plan that
runs through all the buttons
and the branches and the pages
and the options of your game.
I realize that when
you've got randomness
as one of your
core design goals,
you can't predict how your
game is going to play.
But you should be able to
take a look at your game
and know most of the states
that it's going to get in.
And you can create a
checklist that says, hey,
have we exhausted
all the possibilities
that a player will encounter?
Have we tested them all in the
last two builds, yes or no?
And the answer
should probably there
be yes because one
of the things that's
very common with
projects that have
a lot of highly integrated
systems working together
and depend on emergent
behavior-- which
is most games-- is you can
introduce a feature over
here that changes the way that
a feature that you implemented
two weeks ago works.
And you'll never know that it
did that until you go through
and you test and you find that
something that was working
is now broken.
So it is worth it
to take the time
to go back and
check those features
you know nobody touched.
Bug reporting.
Because so many people
are so bad at this,
I'm going to take the time
with a captured audience
to tell you how to do it.
Be kind to your
fellow engineers.
Be kind to yourself, if you
end up getting your own bugs.
Write good defect
reports and not bad ones.
Good bugs include what happened,
what should have happened.
Because it doesn't
do me a lot of good
if you tell me that
the peach mobile
is going 30 miles
per hour if I don't
know why that's a problem.
How do I reproduce it?
If it's obvious to reproduce,
you don't need to include it.
But if it took 38 steps,
include a text file.
How common is the bug?
How serious is the bug?
Is this something that the team
needs to jump on right now,
or is this something that
Sunday afternoon you're
going to look at and
say, eh, ship it.
Because some bugs you look
at and you say, eh, ship it.
But you want to know
that it's there,
and you want to
know how it's going
to affect your game before
you just decide to ship it.
Include some supporting data
if it's going to be helpful,
and it often is.
If you're trying to
describe something visually,
give them a screenshot.
If you can run it
in the debugger
and catch some
debugging code, great.
Save the files.
Know the version of the
game you were using.
Be ready to help
your team member who
has to fix your horrible awful
crash that happens one out
of every four times, and you're
not sure how you made it.
Be willing to help
them recreate it,
because it can be really
hard to recreate bugs.
Finally, know the difference
between a criticism
and a critique, and make
sure that your reports are
critiques of the
game and the bugs
and not criticisms of
your fellow developers
and their ideas.
And when I say criticism,
what I mean here
is an unsupported
opinion usually delivered
in an unprofessional tone.
These purple elephants are
junk and it's totally stupid
that they fly.
A critique is a
statement of opinion
about the game backed up by
examples and hopefully facts.
The purple elephants
make the game too easy
because they can fly.
I can skip almost a
third of the game play
in the bottom area
of the screen.
There's a problem.
There's a reason
why it's a problem.
And there's a fact that
you can talk about,
and you can have opinions.
And it doesn't matter that the
purple elephants go in the game
or not.
You can just talk about what
they're doing in the game.
You don't have to talk
about the person who
put the purple elephants
in the game at all.
So user testing.
I think we've actually
covered this one to death.
But if I did a
lecture about testing
and didn't stop and talk
about why you're doing it,
it would be a little odd.
Once again, every time we
say iterative design, that
means you make a design, you
test it, you get the data,
you move on without actually
testing it with users.
You don't get real data,
et cetera and so forth.
So I think that drum has
been well and truly beaten.
But here's a warning
we haven't really
talked about yet, which
is test-driven design.
Does not mean do what your
testers tell you to do.
Test-driven design means
gather data from your testers,
analyze it, and act on it.
90% of all MIT
students will tell you
that your game is too easy.
They're wrong.
90% of all people who like
to play first person shooters
will tell you that
your game needs a gun.
If you didn't plan on
having a gun in your game,
it probably really
doesn't need a gun.
Testers are often full of
solutions and suggestions
to make your game just
like the game they
wish they were playing.
But you're not trying
to make that game.
You're trying to make the
game you're trying to make.
So when you gather
your data, put it
through the filter of what
your vision of the game is
and what you intend
your game to do,
and don't let your
testers drive your game.
Let your vision and
your data drive it.
So how.
How do you get
ideas from testers?
And how do you actually turn
them into something useful?
So you all remember the
experimental method.
It's actually really
pretty similar.
Going to form a hypothesis,
or ask a question.
Figure out how to get the
data to that question,
collect it, and analyze it.
So forming a question.
What do you need to
know about your game
that your team can't answer?
The more specific you
can be, the easier it is.
Sometimes it is
hard to get specific
because you've got
a game and you've
got a whole lot of
interlinking systems,
and it's hard to figure out
which one is making things
not quite right.
But do your best.
In there a particular mechanic?
Are people having a hard
time or an easy time
getting started on your game?
How engaged are people
in your game play?
Are they playing the
game and grinning,
or are they just sitting
there and hitting the keys?
How many of your players
complete your game
in about the time
you expected them to?
How many of them complete
too quickly or take too long?
So when you're running
scientific experiments,
you try to standardize
your conditions
as much as possible
to get data that can
be compared with each other.
When you're collecting
qualitative data, which
is what most focus
testing data is,
this is actually pretty
hard to do but you
want to try to do it anyway.
So some of the ways
you can do that is by
make sure you're giving each
player the same set of starting
information by having a
script to introduce your game,
to give them any information
about the game they're
going to need because your game
is in too early to have a UI.
Games often don't
have UIs that are
particularly useful while
they want to be tested early.
That's OK, just tell your
players what your UI "should"
tell them.
You can double this
up with user testing
by giving them pictures
of the intended UI,
and you can see if they can
figure it out from there
or not.
But that's advanced
testing tricks.
Have a dedicated observer.
Don't depend on their memory
for what they're looking for
or what they see.
Give them a list
of specific things
to look for that you think
will answer the questions
you need to answer.
Give them space to
write it down with.
And give them the
autonomy to stand back
and just take notes
while someone else
offers your player assistance
or introduces them to the game.
And finally, you really
can't observe everything.
Think about what your players
might be able to tell you
that you can't see.
Write down a few
questions for them
to answer afterwards
if you need to.
Keep it short.
You don't really want to
make somebody write an essay
while they do your testing.
If you can encourage your
players to talk to the game
or to talk out loud
while they play,
that's the greatest thing ever.
The best people I've
ever heard play games
are middle schoolers because
they connect their brain
straight to their mouth
without any filter,
and they're just there.
They're telling you
what they're doing.
why they're doing it.
They're telling you why this
particular aspect of your game
is the worst thing ever, or
why this particular aspect
of your game is the
greatest thing ever.
And you can just sit
there and listen to them
and you know why
they're doing things.
Adults are a lot quieter.
We often don't want to explain
why we're doing something.
Often it's because we don't
know we're supposed to be doing.
And we don't want to admit that
I don't know what I'm doing.
I'm just going to poke
stuff until I figure out
what's going on.
So that's where you
want to watch people.
And if you really need
to, you can lead and say,
why did you do that thing?
Or even better, what
are you thinking?
People will often
answer those questions.
But you really want
to keep those prodding
questions neutral.
Don't say, why did you
do that crazy thing?
Or, what are you
looking for back there?
But just, what are you thinking?
What are you doing?
What's your plan?
That sort of thing.
Once you've got
your data the team
can review it together to notice
trends, spot common problems,
and so on.
And that's where the things
that four or five or a majority
of your testers did or
said or ran into, that's
what you're going to be
pulling out and using
to think about how you're
going to fix those problems.
Or if you noticed a trend
that you hadn't noticed before
that people were really
liking an aspect of your game
you haven't thought
about, it's something
you can work on magnifying
so that you can share it
with everyone.
So for those of you who fell
asleep while I was talking,
the too long didn't
read version really
is who are you testing with,
because your audience will
affect your data.
What are you testing with?
The state of your game
will affect your data.
That shouldn't stop you from
testing with early builds,
but it does mean you need
to adjust your expectations
and make sure your players
are ready to play with it.
And finally, why
are you testing?
Only you can answer
that question.
We can give you a lot of
reasons or suggestions,
but if you're
running a focus test
it really needs to be because
you're looking for data
that your team intends to use.
And you can always use
data to support your game.
You really can.
Even if you don't realize
that you need it, you do.
And I keep saying
"and gather data."
And I talked about observations.
I talked about surveys.
I talked about interviews,
which are our three major tools
unless you are going to go to
all the work of videotaping
and audio recording
and getting releases
from your testers, which
I really don't recommend.
That's more work than
you should be doing.
But the three major tools
really are observing people
and taking notes, asking them
a standard set of questions
afterwards-- either on
paper or in person--
and thinking about
what kind of data
you can gather best with
each of those methods.
If you have 20 different
levels you want someone
to rate at a one to five as
to whether it's good or not,
you should just give
them piece of paper
and when they finish
each level, they
can check a number
between one and five.
If you want to see how
long it takes someone
to get started playing
the game, you probably
just want to watch
them with a timer.
How long does it take them
to get from that first screen
to getting into the game?
And finally, if you want to
get a general impression,
sometimes talking to people
helps bring out things
that you didn't think of.
You can get some
insights you wouldn't
have thought to ask for
by talking with people.
But be a little careful
talking with people,
because people don't
want to tell you
bad things to your face.
They'd rather write the bad
things down on a piece of paper
where they don't have
to admit that they said
bad things about this game.
That covers less for
middle school students,
as I mentioned earlier.
But most people
don't really want
to say mean things
to the person who
made the game, because we don't
want to make people feel bad.
So you need to
balance that out when
you're asking people
questions about well,
how did you like the game?
The answer is usually,
oh, it's great.
Yeah.
So having run
through all of that,
let me fight with my
computer and bring up
a couple of examples.
That's not the right form yet.
So this is a script
created by students
by a team that had a
dedicated QA lead person.
I do not expect your sheets
to look anything like this,
but I want you to see an
example of what someone
did when it was their job
and they were taking time
to get things ready.
So you can see how
serious we are.
And so you've got your
observer instructions.
And what's day's goal?
Finding out if the
feedback in the game
works, along with a
couple of other things.
And there's a testing
script written out
pretty clearly along with
some basic instructions.
Since these teams had a
dedicated focus test lead,
they had someone
who'd spent a lot
of time thinking about
testing and a lot of people
who'd spend a lot of
time working on the game.
So the lead tester
was in the position
of trying to make sure
that the team understood
how to run tests, because they
weren't experts at it either.
So I just embedded all
of the good advice right
into the script.
And there you have it.
And then there's a sheet
to write notes down.
They've got the big questions
that they're worried about,
so they can write down.
They've got space
for other notes.
And it means that whatever
they've got, they've got.
And then finally, it follows
up with a fairly short
questionnaire trying to get
some answers to questions
they're wondering about.
The specifics are always going
to vary from game to game.
Looking at the focus
test sheet from one game
isn't going to help
you wildly with yours.
But you can think about the
way the questions are worded
and the number of questions
so that you're not
overloading people.
I believe these are up
on Stellar as a sample
if you want to download it
and look at it as an example.
Finally, the paper
we expect you to do.
So this is the focus
test report which
is also download-able
on Stellar,
I think in either Word or Rich
Text Format so you can use it.
When we say we expect you to
turn in a focus test report,
this is what we're
expecting you to turn in.
If you take a look
at it, it walks you
through the whole
process and there's
a space for most of this stuff.
So what's the goal
of the focus test?
Record what happened
at the focus test
and what are you going
to do afterwards.
When you are planning your focus
test for this afternoon later
in class, I recommend you
download this and use it
as your sheet to
record notes on,
because it'll help make sure
that you get the data that we
are asking you to get.
And I think that's
actually most of what
I have to say about testing.
Are there any questions?
PHILLIP TAN: I have a question.
What's currently using
some bug database,
and if so, what are
folks currently using?
Or let me rephrase that.
Who has used a bug
database before?
What are some of the ones
that you're familiar with?
AUDIENCE: Chehra.
PHILLIP TAN: Chehra?
AUDIENCE: Bugzilla.
PHILLIP TAN: Which one?
PHILLIP TAN: Oh, Bugzilla.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Buganizer.
PHILLIP TAN: Which one is it?
PHILLIP TAN: Buganizer?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: Oh.
AUDIENCE: I use [INAUDIBLE].
PHILLIP TAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] That's
the [INAUDIBLE] database, yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: And
as Sara mentioned,
you can also just use a Google
spreadsheet or something.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] is
a great bug database too.
PHILLIP TAN: There is always
this intermediate step
between someone entering
a bug into a bug database
and then deciding that they're
going to fix it, right?
So priority, somebody
actually says
I think the bug that
the characters are
too short or something,
and then the art director
says no, not a bug.
Will not fix that.
So just because you're entering
something in a bug database
doesn't necessarily
mean that your team's
committed to actually
spending time on that.
But when a team does decide
that, OK, this is a bug.
Maybe because it
crashes the game.
Maybe because it's
actually not how
we want the game to perform.
It needs to be entered
into your task list.
So that means your
task list is changing
and you need to be able
to put that in a priority.
Possibly, this bug is
more serious than some
of the planned tasks that
you already have on there.
So you need to rearrange
that so that [INAUDIBLE].
Something else that Sara
mentioned very briefly,
but I want to
stress, MIT students
are actually horrible testers.
I've heard this many times from
many different companies here
and [INAUDIBLE].
MIT students are not a
representative population
of the general public.
You look at systems differently.
You look at screens differently.
So even though most
of your testing
that we're going to be
doing this semester,
I imagine that a lot of testing
you're going to do on your own
is going to be with other people
in your dorms, for instance,
and that's fine for this class.
But don't think that it's normal
to use even university students
as your only test audience.
That's really not representative
of the general public.
MIT students in particular.
PROFESSOR: MIT students
do [INAUDIBLE].
PHILLIP TAN: The final
thing, as Sara mentioned,
user testing in two contexts.
One for overall category of
you are testing with users
and then it's broken down
to more specifically, focus
testing and user testing.
And you may be wondering
why user testing is used
and that [INAUDIBLE] two
different things, as Sara said,
it's good to be more granular.
What we normally refer
to as usability testing,
as Sara mentioned, has
only fairly recently
become the standard name for it.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Yeah.
PHILLIP TAN: Back in the '90s
and even the early 2000s,
user testing and
usability testing
were basically the
same thing, because we
were talking about websites
and enterprise software.
We were not talking about games.
So the only kind of user
testing that you'd be doing,
putting a piece of software
in front of someone,
getting feedback, was
usability testing.
That's why they had the
same name for so long.
But now there's focus testing,
which is very, very applicable
not just for games but also for
things like user experience.
I had not heard that term
user experience [INAUDIBLE].
So where it's not just can the
player figure out what to do,
but the person actually
having the desired experience
for playing the game.
That's why now there's
multiple names for that.
PROFESSOR: Thank you.
Then I think I'm out of here.
I'm going to sneak
off with my computer.
GENEVIEVE CONLEY: Hi, guys.
My name is Genevieve Conley.
I'm a researcher at Riot.
And some other
terms that you might
have heard for that, user
experience researcher, user
researcher, or the way we
were just talking about it,
like user tester basically.
And a little bit about me.
I graduated from MIT in 2010.
I got my degree in Course 9.
And I actually worked
at the MIT Gambit game
lab on a couple games there.
So that's actually where I got
my start doing user testing,
was in the summer projects
we would run play tests
with local community
members, have them come in,
and that's where I actually
did my first user tests.
So I work at Riot Games.
How many of you guys have heard
of League of Legends before?
OK.
How many of you actively
play League of Legends?
OK, good.
So I'll give a little bit
of context on the game
just so I'm not losing anybody.
And I'll try to
make sure I explain
all of our jargon, because
sometimes when you're in a game
company you just start using
the language like everybody
speaks that language.
But a little bit about Riot
is we make League of Legends.
And our core mission
is that we aspire
to be the most player-focused
game company in the world.
And this is going to
be relevant to what
I'm talking about today,
because you can't really
be player-focused if you
don't talk to your players.
So what this means at
Riot is we think about all
of our decisions in terms of
how much player value it adds,
or how much player pain
something negative causes.
So this is like-- I don't
know if any of you familiar--
we have an eSports
scene, and right now
we're in the middle of
our world championships.
And we created a video and
a song that would basically,
we hoped to be the anthem
of the world championship.
And this is something that a
couple people at the studio
thought was really important, so
they just went out and made it.
And the point was just to
make the players pumped up
about worlds and to
give them a song that
represented how they feel.
And this is just a small
example of something
that happens at
Riot where we really
just want to do
something that we think
players will think is cool.
And one of the
ways if we do that
is through play testing
and user testing.
And I'm going to use a little
bit different terminology,
so I'll make sure that I
tie it back into the way
that Sara's been talking
about it as we go.
So a little about
League of Legends.
It's generally a 5v5 game.
It's a team oriented game.
So you play as a
member of a team.
And you usually play a specific
role or position on that team,
just like basketball.
And you play as one
of many champions.
And it's online and
it's competitive.
So like I said, we have
an eSports scene where
you play against another team.
And you go basically across this
map, try to take objectives,
and ultimately
blow up this thing
called the Nexus which
is a giant crystal
on the other side of the map.
And you play as a champion.
And these are player
characters that each
have an individual set of
skills, different play styles,
and there's over 120
of them in our game.
So even though each
game is session based--
you don't level up your
character necessarily
over the lifetime
of playing the game,
each session is a new session--
there's lots of different ways
to play because we have lots
of different characters, which
I'll talk to in a little bit.
So one of things
that I talked about
is it's really hard to
be player-focused if you
don't talk to your players.
And one of things at
Riot is that we all
play League of Legends.
In fact, some of
us play it a lot.
Some of us play a lot at work.
But just because you
play your own game
doesn't mean that you
actually know what it's
like for all of your players.
And using MIT students
is a great example.
If you guys just play
with MIT students,
you might not know what
it's like for people
in other countries, for example.
So one of things we
try to do is make sure
that we understand
our players broadly
and know that we
are our players,
but we are a small
sub-segment of our players.
The way we use
research is it equips
us to understand player beliefs,
their needs, their desires,
and their relationship
with the game
and with other
people in the game.
And what this allows us to
do is design experiences.
So there's specific
experiences, interactions
that we're hoping to design.
So in general when we're
creating a feature,
we have a set of goals that
we're trying to achieve.
And what we want to do is
we want to help designers.
developers, QA,
artists, we want to help
them achieve these goals.
So we want to know exactly what
they're trying to do and then
get them feedback on how
well those goals are being
communicated to players,
how well they're actually
able to interact with
those, and then what
their reception is as a result.
So the way I'm going
to break this down
is play tests and user
labs, which is essentially
the way we were talking
about it before,
is play tests and user tests.
So play test is the backbone
of creating your game.
It's really, really
difficult to create a game
without play testing it.
So I'm glad that's really part
of how you guys are designing
your games.
And play tests basically
allow us to quickly gather
information about
a game or a feature
to see how it's working.
And typically, this
is done with resources
that are readily available.
So people in your dorms, people
in your class, or at Riot,
we often do it with other
Rioters, and even on the team.
And some of the benefits
we can get out of this
is we can identify
technical issues.
Now, Sara talked
about a specific type
of this, which is quality
assurance testing, which
is less what I'm talking about.
I'm more talking about
testing with your team
to just quickly identify
technical issues that
might prevent you from
playing that game.
You can also look at
things like balance.
So in a competitive game
like League of Legends,
you play against other players.
And if one type of character
is really overpowered
or has a significant advantage
over another type of character,
we can quickly identify
that through play testing.
So for instance, our designers
have two play tests a day
where they test their
in-progress champions
to see if there's anything
basically game breaking
like that that they can quickly
identify and iterate on.
We can also look
at things for fun.
I mean, this is the
most obvious one.
But it's really important
when you're making a game,
if the game is supposed to be
fun, that it is actually fun.
And in our case, we do
want to have a fun game.
So we have a whole group
of designers and developers
that have a team which
is known as the play team
and they make
temporary game modes.
So I don't know if
anybody played recently,
but we had a big in-game
event called Shurima,
and we had this game
mode called Ascension.
And when they were
developing that,
they were often several times
a day-- many, many times a day,
in some cases--
testing every iteration
that they made to that
game mode to make sure
that it was actually fun.
And a lot of times
what you'll find
is that your game isn't
necessarily fun sometimes.
And that's OK, because each
time you make a change,
you're getting closer
to that fun experience.
One day, you'll be playing
your game and like, oh my gosh,
it's actually fun now.
This is great.
Let's do this.
So it's a really good
way to get that feedback.
And another specific area
that we're looking for a lot
when we play test is clarity.
And clarity is a
word that we use
to mean basically how
clear is the information--
either the visual information
or the mechanical information--
how well is that being
communicated to players?
So this could be
something like with UI,
if you just have a
picture and you show it
to players or to your
dorm-mates, your classmates,
how easily are they able to
identify what a button means?
Or which things are
clickable and not clickable.
Those things are all
really, really important
in a game like
ours where we have
five people on a team, 10
people on the map, each
with their own set of
abilities and visual effects.
And there could be a
lot of visual clutter
if we didn't think about
this type of thing.
And then the way we typically
get these, at least at Riot, is
like I said, team tests.
That's the example I used with
the designers and the play
team.
They're just playing
within their team
frequently to make sure that
they can quickly and easily
give each other feedback.
Quality assurance
test is another type
that's a very specific
implementation of this,
which Sara spoke to.
And in house "guerrilla
tests"-- and I always
have to be careful how
I say "guerrilla," not
"gorilla." "Guerrilla."
This is when we bring
other Rioters who
aren't part of a team who
maybe haven't had exposure
to that particular feature.
This is particularly
useful for things
like clarity or usability tests,
because we don't necessarily
need to have that perception
or that sentiment that
is really unique to players.
What we need here
instead is just see, hey,
how easily is this usable for
a reasonably tech savvy person?
But even then, of course, there
are some cultural differences.
There's some
hardware differences.
So it's a first phase when you
do them as guerrilla testing.
And you always want to make
sure that you follow up
with real players
after the fact.
So user labs, this is
what I really focus in.
So I use a lot of
different methods at Riot,
but one of the key
ways that we're
able to get player feedback
is by bringing players
to Riot to have
them play the game.
So this is a way to
help us understand
how real players will
actually approach a feature.
What we get out of this is
really, really important.
We get reception and interest.
Like, how stoked are players
going to be about something,
or what we call the
table flip reaction.
Which is like, we're
working on an update
to Summoner's Rift right now.
And it was early on.
It was really important
for us to know,
were players going
to be really upset
that we were changing something
that's so key to the game.
So we made sure to
loop them on very early
in on the process to see how
they were responding to changes
we were going to make.
We also look for things like
usage patterns and errors.
And this is
important that we get
a broad swath of
different types of players
to look at this type
of thing, especially
with things like we
just updated the client.
Making sure that the changes
we made to the interface
weren't going to
confuse players--
experienced players who
were used to our old version
and new players
who would be coming
into our game for
the first time.
We also look at
needs and desires.
And this is not like Maslov's--
Maslow's hierarchy of needs.
It's more like, what are
things that players really
want from our game?
And understanding that
can be difficult sometimes
because, like I said,
we all play our game.
We're very entrenched
in this experience.
We have our own
experience in the game
that we feel very
strongly about.
But understanding that
other players might
have different
needs and desires,
and understanding
what proportion that
represents within our
broader player base,
these are really important
things to understand.
How we get this is a
lot of different ways
that I'm actually going
to go into in a little bit
more detail.
And each one has a
specific application,
but there are a few
that we use pretty
much in every user
lab, which I'm
going to go through right now.
So the first is something
we just talked about,
which is just observation.
And I bring this up because it's
something that anybody can do.
You don't need a dedicated
researcher like myself.
You guys should and
will be doing this.
And so in this
case, I have Chris,
who is a developer at Riot,
sitting in for a player.
And I have [? Jisan, ?] who
is another researcher at Riot,
sitting over his shoulder
watching him play.
In our case, we typically
just have one researcher
in the room both
taking the notes
and doing the
observation, just because
of resource limitations.
And because we've done this a
lot and it's our full time job.
So in this case,
[? Jisan ?] is watching
Chris interact with the client.
And you can see in his hand,
he's actually got the script--
or what we call
protocol-- in his hands
so he can remember what things
he should be looking for,
what things he wants to say.
In this case, we don't generally
try to use it as a script.
We try to use it as
a memory refresher.
That way, players can feel
really comfortable with us
and feel like they
have a relationship
and can have a
comfortable conversation.
One of the ways we achieve
this is through what
we call the Think Aloud
protocol, which is what Sara
was referencing,
which is basically we
try to make sure that
they have this direct link
from their mind to their mouth.
And there's a couple
ways to achieve this
that I'll speak to,
but the goal of this
is we want to know exactly
what the game is communicating
to players, and then how
players are processing that
and creating an internal model.
And the best way
to do that is just
to step back and
let them tell you
exactly what they're seeing.
And if you aren't quite
sure what they're seeing,
then you can follow up, which
I'll get to in a second.
So here's an example of a player
who's seeing our character
Lucian, who is a
champion who was released
fairly recently in the game.
She's seeing him before
he had been released
in a work in progress
state and giving us
feedback on what she sees.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-I can see that he walks
faster than the normal--
[END PLAYBACK]
GENEVIEVE CONLEY: Sorry, we
forgot to plug in the audio.
I think you guys could
hear it all right.
All right.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-[INAUDIBLE].
GENEVIEVE CONLEY: Oops.
-I can see that he walks faster
than the normal character
would, but his animation
doesn't make it seem so.
It seems like he takes
a really big stride,
but I was imagining him
to walk really fast.
But it seems like it
looks like that way.
[END PLAYBACK]
GENEVIEVE CONLEY: So
this is an example
where the player has just
brought this up to us that she
expected him to move one
way, and he's actually
operating in a different way.
You can think of this
is as like, basically
a violation of
expectations, which
is often what we're looking for
especially with our characters.
Does what you see and what you
hear about a champion match
with how they actually play?
So one way you can do this
is to just let them talk.
And it is really important
not to be giving feedback on
whether or not you
think they're correct,
especially if they
do have a question.
It's also really important
not to be judgmental, right?
So the way you phrase
your questions,
even if you aren't
actually being judgmental,
sometimes players might think
that you're judging them.
So one of the contexts
we give players upfront
is always for us,
since we actually
didn't work on the game or the
feature that they're seeing,
we can say, we
didn't work on this.
It's really important that
you give us honest feedback.
I'm not going to go
home and cry at night,
so I want you to give me
totally honest feedback.
And we also let them
know that sometimes we're
going to ask them questions,
and we're asking it
so that we can
understand what they're
thinking because
that's what we're
interested in understanding.
We're not asking
it because there
is a right or wrong answer.
So one of the ways
that makes it easier
to make sure that
we understand what
their mental model
of the game is
is a follow-up with
some probing questions.
So the player in
the previous example
was pretty clear about
what she was seeing
and why it violated
her expectations,
but sometimes players
don't necessarily
know why it doesn't actually
fit what they expected.
Or they might know that
something's frustrating,
but they're not necessarily
giving you the answer why.
So one of the ways
you can follow it up
is either with probing
questions, which
you ask in the moment, or you
can follow up with interviews
after the fact.
So here's an example of
[? Jisan ?] following up
with a player who just saw
Lucian for the first time.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-How was that play [INAUDIBLE]?
-I thought it was fun.
I thought it was
[? different. ?]
-What makes it fun and
something different about it?
-So he, I guess, normal
[INAUDIBLE] skills,
just increased the intensity.
A lot of his skills based off
of move speed and [INAUDIBLE]
speed, and I guess he
feels [? confident. ?]
[END PLAYBACK]
GENEVIEVE CONLEY: So
this is an example.
A lot of times
you'll find this, is
that when you ask
that initial question,
you get a short response.
And what we're always trying
to do as researchers is invite
a conversation where they're
just really comfortable telling
us exactly what they feel and
giving us a lot of detail.
So in the first question, he
asked a really broad opening
question, which
was "how was that?"
He didn't even ask,
"how did that feel,"
which might lead in
a certain direction--
although that would be an
appropriate question as well.
He left it wide
open for the player
to take us where they
wanted to talk about it.
So the player
mentioned that it was
fun and something different.
So [? Jisan ?] wanted
to get more depth
into what does that actually
mean, because that alone
doesn't give us
enough direction to be
able to provide to our
designers to say what was good,
what was working.
So he mirrored exactly what
the player said back at him.
He said, oh, what
was fun and what
was the thing that
made it feel different?
And then the player, that
way we're not actually
putting our own
spin on interpreting
what we think they're saying is
fun or maybe what's different.
We're just mirroring
exactly back
what they said so that they
can give us more detail.
You have to be
careful with that,
because you also don't want
to sound cold and clinical
like you're sitting in an
office somewhere writing down
everything they say,
which you will be.
You want to make it feel like
it's a natural conversation.
So we're really
lucky because we get
to work with League
of Legends players
so we already have a
connection built up with them
where we can talk about it, but
it's really important that you
make that as hey, I want
to know what you think.
You're really valuable.
Let's just have a
conversation about it.
And it can be really
challenging sometimes.
So this is one that
you guys are already
pretty familiar with,
too, is part of interviews
that I've clumped in here is
basically the questionnaire.
Sara gave you guys
some great context
about when this might be useful.
Here's an example
of when we use it
in League of Legends research.
So this is an example
with Azir, who
is a character who just came
out in League of Legends.
This is actually from
quite a long time
ago when he was in
the concept phase.
And this is something
we do actually
with most of our concepts, is
we put them in front of players
before they go into
development to see, hey,
is this something
that feels like it
fits in the world of
League of Legends?
Is it clear where maybe
the source of power is?
And does this look like a
champion you would actually
want to play?
Now, we don't use data to
drive decisions at Riot.
I want to make
that really clear.
We use it to inform.
So just because something
wasn't resonating
with players in
our labs wouldn't
mean that we would
cancel a character.
It's just a way for
us to get feedback
for our designers who
already have their experience
and the experience
testing with other Rioters
to help them make
informed decisions.
So what's useful about a
questionnaire in this case
is that we can compare
across champions over time
and across different
roles or positions
and see what is resonating
and what does good look like.
We also use this as
a jumping off point.
So we start with
a questionnaire,
and then we go into a more
detailed interview about it
to make sure that we're
getting enough detail to be
able to provide useful
information to the designers.
So you guys are also
probably pretty familiar
with the idea of
experiments in general.
But part of research testing
can be devising experiments.
So we often hire people
from psychology backgrounds
or research
backgrounds in academia
because they have experience
setting up experiments.
So this is like the classic one.
I don't know if you guys
have already covered
this, the Engelbart experiment.
OK.
So this is foundational
human computer interaction.
It's one of the
most cited studies.
And it's English, Engerlbart,
and Berman basically
were looking for a
way to improve a way
to interact with a screen
or text manipulation.
And what they
proposed was something
that was radical and
was called the "mouse."
Maybe you've heard of it.
So that thing in
the right, I know
it's not a really
clear photo, but that
is one of the first early
prototypes of a mouse.
And what they wanted to
do is they want to see,
is this better than some
of these other interactions
out there.
Qualitative experience alone
might not be a very strong way
to prove it in this
case, especially when you
can collect quantitative
data to back it up.
So what they did is
they used the time
that it took to complete a
task, a very specific task that
was given across all these
different ways of manipulating
text.
And they saw how many errors
the user made in this case.
So you can see that the
mouse did pretty well
in terms of time overall.
It didn't take the
participants very long
to be able to complete the task.
But it had very
few errors, which
made it overall the best
out of these different ways
to select text.
And you can see some of
the other ones on here
were things like knee control,
joystick, a graphicon, which
is like an arc drawer, a
light pen, and a joystick.
And all of these were
ways that we could
have gone instead of the mouse.
But based on some
of this research,
they were able to
improve their design
and now you can see I'm
using one right now.
And as part of the experimental
approach, I broke it out,
but there's a
specific way you can
look at it, which is using
physiological techniques.
And there are many, and I'm
just going to cover two.
And typically, these are
used for very specific types
of research.
They're very exciting.
So oftentimes, you'll see people
want to use them on everything.
But they're very particularly
useful for certain cases.
So this is an example of eye
tracking, which is basically
fundamentally, we
put a camera up
that's able to specially
track where eye movements are.
And there are more sophisticated
ways you can look at this--
and I'm sure a bunch
of researchers at MIT
could tell you a
lot more about it.
But in this case, it
was pretty simple.
We were just looking at
where people were looking
on the screen and how
often and how long
they were looking there.
So you can see the
red parts of the map
here are the parts where there
are more intense gazes or more
gazes overall.
So unsurprisingly
to probably most
of the League of
Legends players in here,
or you guys as
gamers in general,
the mini map has a lot of gaze.
The bottom part, which is where
the abilities are displayed,
also has a lot of gaze.
That has a lot of
information that's
really relevant to players
like the cool down timer,
basically when the ability
is going to be ready again.
And the center of the screen
is where most of the action
happens.
So this type of information
is helpful for us.
If we want to, for instance,
introduce new information
on the screen,
we'd want to know,
hey, are we going
to introduce this
in a place that's going to get
a lot of traffic naturally.
But also is it going
to interrupt things
that that gaze is there for
a very important reason,
and maybe we shouldn't
interrupt that.
So we can help us to inform
those types of decisions.
There's also many other
types of physiological,
and I'll just hint at
one right now which
is things like galvanic
skin response, anything that
has to do with
physiological arousal,
either for stress or excitement.
These can help with situations
where maybe players wouldn't
be able to vocalize
why something
was frustrating or exciting.
Or it can also help
combat some biases
like recency
effect, where if you
ask a player at
the end of the lab
or at the end of a play
test what was interesting
or what was frustrating,
they might preference
things that were at the end.
Or they might preference things
that were really emotionally
significant for them, but might
forget smaller things that
are still maybe small
frustrating things that
build up over time.
So none of this is
really that interesting
if I don't give you an example
of how we actually do at Riot.
So here's a case study.
And I actually presented this
last year as part of a talk
that we did at MIT.
So I apologize if a little
bit is re-run for you guys.
I'll try to spice it up
a little bit as I go.
So I'm going to be talking
about Lucian, who I introduced
to you guys earlier.
He is one of the player
characters or champions
in League of Legends.
So where we always
start as researchers,
and part of the job that I
haven't really alluded to
yet is we spend a lot of time
talking to our designers,
to our developers, to our
artists, to our producers,
to make sure we
understand the goals
they're trying to achieve.
And I don't know
how many of you guys
got to catch August
Browning's talk last night,
but for the champion
designers, they
start with a very specific
idea of what goals
they're trying to achieve.
What is this player
character going to feel like?
What are you going to feel
like when you play it?
What is the mechanics
supposed to feel like?
What is the theme
How does this
resonate with players?
How does it fit in
League of Legends?
These are all really
important questions for them
that they're constantly
asking themselves.
And in the case of
Lucian, he was supposed
to feel fast, sleek, speedy.
He was like a gun ninja.
Like pew, pew.
No?
All right.
Trying to see if you
guys were awake there.
And he's a range
damage character
with finesse game play.
And he basically has
the high skill ceiling.
And what that means is basically
he's harder to pick up,
but when you master him it's
a really rewarding feeling.
So that's a trade off
between accessibility, maybe
how quickly a player
can pick him up,
or what level a player
for a reward of how
rewarding that feels when
you do master that champion.
And some of the challenges in
this were, this guy, his theme
is pretty different.
His equilibrium style, if
you've ever seen that movie.
And that's not something
we had necessarily
done that much in League
of Legends before,
so we wanted to make
sure, does he even fit.
And we also wanted
to know how do
you let a player feel super
fast and speedy in what
is essentially an
RTS style game.
It's a challenge.
So this is what the test
plan eventually looked like.
It's not necessarily
where we started from.
But we started with
concept testing,
and then we went through
actually three lab studies
with iteration in between
based on the feedback
we got from players.
And after he launched, we did
some post-launch evaluation.
So step one, just like
I showed you earlier,
was to do this concept testing.
And we got some pretty good
feedback based on that.
His fantasy was
good with players.
They liked the mood.
[THUD]
They felt like he fit.
Are you all right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GENEVIEVE CONLEY:
And he made sense
for the role of an AD carry,
which again is like a range
damage dealer in this case.
So he had high appeal scores and
the theme felt really strong,
but one thing we very
quickly identified--
it's a little hard
to see on this one--
but his guns were
different colors.
So players expected the
guns to do different things
based on their colors, which
was not what we were planning.
So this was very
good early feedback
before we got very far
into development where
we could pivot and make sure
that the idea of the two
guns doing the same
thing was conveyed.
So based on the
feedback we got, we
were able to give
that to the designers
and they continued
their development.
And then after a
little bit of time,
we were able to take
it into the lab.
So we started with a
Lucian that was designed
to be a speedy range assassin.
He had a double shot
and a utility kit.
And when I refer to
kit, just to be clear,
that means his set of abilities.
And characters in
League of Legends
generally have three abilities
and then an ultimate ability,
where the ultimate is like
the super big bad power
that you get after some
leveling of the character.
So I blew the reveal
here, but in the first lab
we found out that he didn't
really feel that sleek
and fast.
He felt stiff.
He planted and then fired
his double shot, which
made him feel like a turret.
And people did like
his visual theme.
They thought it was
compelling, but it just
didn't match his play style.
So we took this back to the
designers we said, hey guys.
Here's the videos.
Here's the notes.
We usually make a
highlight reel based
on what we see to
support our evidence so
that the designers can get
enough feedback from that,
as they are our
subject matter experts
and really know how to
interpret what they see.
And we said, OK.
Let's go back.
You guys take some
time, do some changes.
We'll take it in the lab again.
So we did lab study two.
And this time, we had a
different Lucian to bring in.
This time, he was more mobile.
He was basically a
range [INAUDIBLE],
running gun, double shot guy.
Well, we had a little bit of
a mixed bag of results here.
He did feel a little bit faster.
But some poses and
animations felt awkward.
And he was high speed
in the numbers-- which
I'll talk about in a
second-- but he still
felt slow for some reason.
But worst of all, we
got quotes like this one
about the ultimate,
which was "It
worked in the way I did
not want it to work,"
which is a pretty good sign
that something's wrong.
So we took all this
back to designers again.
We said, hey guys--
and the animators
and the artists in this case,
of course-- and we said,
he feels slow.
His ultimate doesn't
really have the usability
that people expect, but the
double shot theme is working,
so we're definitely
on the right track
and players are still very
excited about this champion.
So now we're in a
bind, and this is often
the case when you're working
with research from players
because they're not
always able to articulate
exactly what's wrong
because they don't
have the context that you do.
So this is why it's
so important for us
as researchers to pair with
our designers, our artists,
our producers, and
our players to be
able to get the
right kind of data
to make informed decisions.
So here was our problem.
The frame delay between
his basic attacks--
which is actually very,
very low in this last lab.
Usually that means
things feel fast.
It's a pretty standard way when
we're developing characters
to be like, OK, this
will feel faster.
He also had a very high
base movement speed,
which means that the time it
took him to run from point A
to point B was
pretty high relative
to the rest of our champions.
And if that weren't
enough, he actually
had a dash ability which
means that he could just
jump basically from
one point to another.
All of these things should
have made him feel fast.
But players were saying
he didn't feel fast,
so there was something wrong.
So our designers and our
artists and our producers
took all of this information
back, looked at the videos,
play tested the heck out of it,
and came to this conclusion.
They increased the
ability responsiveness
and they changed how animation
flowed from one state
to another.
So I'm not an
artist, but what this
means to me is that
they are basically
able to make the transitions
from animation a, animation
b, or ability a to
ability b, and make
those feel more natural.
Not like me.
And they also gave more
feedback to the double shot.
And again, this is where
subject matter expertise is
so important because our
animators, our visual artists,
our designers knew
this bag of tricks
to be able to apply to it.
And finally, they
were able to make
the ultimate ability clearer.
So they were able
to the telegraph
better what it was
actually supposed
to do so that players would
have more accurate expectations.
So we took it to lab
study number three.
We put it in and
finally, the game
play anesthetics
fit the concept,
and players were quite happy.
But not everything is
always happy ending,
everything is perfect.
There was still some confusion
about how the ultimate was
supposed to work.
We found that players
wanted more control of it.
Basically how the
ultimate currently works
is he locks his arms forward
and shoots in that direction.
So if you stray
left to right, he
continues shooting in
that direction which,
for some players,
was pretty confusing.
Now what they expected based
on some of our other champions,
and it wasn't able for them
to learn it in one session.
So one of the things
that we have to take away
from that is labs have some
external validity problems,
which basically means that
we're sitting in a lab.
There's not other
players around.
They're often not
playing on live.
There's a lot of things that
are different in our test
situations than real life.
Usually, you wouldn't
try to master
a champion in one session.
So this is one of those
cases where we put it out
to our designers and they
decided, and we supported,
that he was going to be a high
skill ceiling champion, which
meant that players were
going to need some time
to learn how to play him.
And that just because they
didn't learn him in one session
didn't mean that they
wouldn't learn him over time.
So this is what Lucian looked
like when he did go live.
And it helps if
I play the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[WARFARE SOUNDS]
GENEVIEVE CONLEY: So
he's in the top there.
Pew, pew.
[WARFARE SOUNDS]
GENEVIEVE CONLEY: So you
can see his dash there.
[END PLAYBACK]
GENEVIEVE CONLEY: So yeah,
sometimes a little confusing
if you don't play
the game to have
to watch 10 champions all in
one little team fight like that.
But ultimately, the
important part's there.
He's using his ultimate
and he dashed at the end.
Ultimately, ended up
actually delivering
on player expectations
for this champion.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
We don't need to
watch that again.
So what did we learn?
Well, we knew going
into it that Lucian
was going to be a difficult
champion to get right.
And we also learned
that, you know
what, it's OK to take a champion
back to the lab multiple times
if we really feel that
it's worth the effort.
We knew that his
theme was compelling,
but there was something
that wasn't just matching up
between his mechanics, his
visuals, and his theme.
And this is one of those things
is that everything on paper
can be totally 100%
right, but if players
don't agree with it or
players aren't feeling
those goals that
you're trying to hit,
there's going to be a problem.
So we're able to collaborate
with our subject matter
experts, with our
players, in order
to get the experience right.
And I mean, I'll say it again.
Just because the mechanics
stacked up correctly
does not mean that
it necessarily will
in the feeling, which is why
you play test it in house,
why you play test it with
other people at your studio
or at your school, and
ideally, why you test it
with the people who are actually
going to play your game.
And then we also learned
that you can sometimes
have these trade-offs.
It goes back to what
you hear from players.
Sometimes they're going
to make suggestions
and you have to look for
the note behind the note.
It's like, what is
actually the problem?
You guys are the
subject matter experts.
You're going to be able to
look at what they're saying
and never take it as,
from players, a criticism.
Always think about it as if
they said something wrong,
there's something that has
to be causing the problem.
What is it underneath
their note that's
actually causing that problem?
Let's look for that thing.
And we're still
iterating after launch.
That's one thing that's typical
with our champions is that yes,
we do play tests with players.
Yes, we do play tests in house.
But once we launch
the champion, there
are thousands and
thousands of play tests
with real players on live.
And that's when we learn
about things that happen maybe
at scale or under very
specific situations,
or for things that we
didn't account for,
for these external
validity concerns.
So we keep iterating.
And in the case of
Lucian, we actually
continue to collect
metrics and user sentiment
through things like surveys
and through game data
to understand how he was doing.
And based on this,
we're able to make
more iterations, fine
tune, and hopefully
make him a little
bit more accessible.
And today, Lucian is well
regarded, widely played.
And if you watch the
professional matches
in the world championship,
he's use quite frequently.
All right, you guys, I
hope I didn't bore you.
My name is Genevieve, again.
If you guys ever
have any questions,
you can feel free to reach out
to me at gconley@riotgames.com.
My Summoner name in game, if
you play, is RiotCapernoited.
And you can also find
me on Twitter there.
I'm always happy to
answer questions.
Thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: We get
a 10 minute break.
PROFESSOR: So 10 minute break.
Come back at 2:20 and be ready
to start working on your focus
test stuff.
OK, welcome back to class.
Now that you've had a chance
to be talked at a whole lot,
we're going to go ahead
and ask you to actually do.
The plan is to give you about 10
minutes to meet in your groups,
plan your test.
I actually strongly
recommend you just grab
a copy of the focus test,
either in the Word version
or the RTF version
of off Stellar
so you've got that as a guide.
Sit down, plan your test and
how you're going to run it.
We'll give you 10
minutes for that.
Then we'll have about
45 minutes for people
to circulate and test.
And one of the things you
should also be planning
is when your team
members will be
out testing other people's
games and when your team members
will be observing.
Just given the number of people
in class, the number of games
we have, and the number
of people on the team,
chances are good that you aren't
going to be either observing
or testing all the time.
You're probably going
to have to wait.
But go ahead and
circulate, take the time
to watch other teams
doing focus testing.
Try not to watch
a game in progress
that you're going to focus test.
If you realize that
you're just sitting
around waiting for a
chance to focus test,
let the team know that
you're in line next.
I'd rather you pulled
out a book and read it
than watched someone
else play a game
you're about to focus test.
It will be more useful for
the poor people who you're
testing for if you
haven't already seen
somebody do all those things.
That doesn't mean
hide in the corner
and read a book because
there's too many people
wandering around testing games.
We do expect everybody to
participate both sides.
Observe and test.
So try to balance
that out a bit.
We'll circulate and
keep an eye on things.
And if it looks like at
some point nobody's actually
testing, you're all sitting
around twiddling your thumbs,
we'll end it early.
I don't know how long
this testing session will
take because we haven't had
such large teams on this project
before.
So it's a little harder for me
to know what the amount of time
is.
After that, we'll give
you some more time
to talk in your own
teams and come up
with the what are the results of
your test to analyze your data.
And then we'll ask
somebody to come down
and for each team give us the
summary of your focus test
report.
How did your focus
test turn out?
What did you learn?
Do you have a plan for what
you're going to do with it,
or are you still figuring
out how you'll deal with it?
Those are all
reasonable things given
you only had 10 minutes
to look at your data.
Thank you.
It is 2:23.
At 2:33, we'll go ahead
and start focus testing.
Actually, I'm going
to give you 15 minutes
to get set up, because I
just realized you probably
need 10 minutes to talk and
then probably five minutes
to make sure you have a
machine up and running.
So I apologize, it's going
to be 15 minutes to plan
and prepare for your test.
So that's 2:38 at this point.
[CHATTER]
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think he just wants to--
PROFESSOR: OK.
You should be ready
to go now, I hope.
And actively go ahead.
You should have a
computer ideally set up
to run your game.
Who is actually ready
to run a focus test?
PHILIP TAN: Everyone who
is manning a demo computer,
a computer ready to run
the game, put your hand up.
All stand up so
that we can see you.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, go
ahead and stay up so
we can see where you are.
PHILIP TAN: I'm not
seeing any hands
from these teams over here.
OK.
All right.
As I said that, someone
is standing up back there.
How about the Sparkly
Redemption team?
OK, all right.
There's someone
there to run a game.
All right.
PROFESSOR: So close
all the laptops
that are not actually running
the game would be my advice,
and then let's go
ahead and get started.
PHILIP TAN: All right.
Start playing each
other's games.
Go.
PROFESSOR: Yep.
[CHATTER]
PROFESSOR: Next time, we'll
ask them to have two or three.
PHILIP TAN: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: As part
of the Stellar thing.
He was talking about the--
AUDIENCE: I got
the FOA for free.
PROFESSOR: OK.
It's OK if you don't
have a plan of action
as you're looking
at your results
as long as you've gotten ideas
to what you're seeing out
of your data.
It's hard to look at your
data, get it evaluated,
talk about it, and
figure out what
you're going to do about
it all in 10 minutes.
We are giving you a short
amount of time because we're
running out of time.
That said, let's get started
with Sparkly Redemption.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So we
had a small hiccup
when we started where we didn't
have-- part of our core game
is collecting sparklies, and we
didn't have a version with that
when we started play testing.
So we actually got to test
out some different movement
controls that we
were trying out,
which actually turned out to
be good because the controls
that we liked, which was
right clicking with the mouse
and then left clicking
to shoot, a lot of people
had a lot of trouble with that.
So it was a good thing that
we messed up and then got
some information from that.
Then we got a version
with sparklies working,
and there was a big bug where
if you killed all the monsters,
they never respond.
So that bug has now been
fixed in the last 10 minutes,
so that was good.
Other than we, we got just
random things like people
staying in the corner
and just shooting,
as opposed to just moving around
the map like we want them to.
So we have a few problems that
we have to figure out that.
Right now, we don't
know the answers.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm with Lost Underground.
As a refresher on
our game, the idea
is that you are lost underground
in the darkness trying
to find an exit.
And so as part of our
game, we have this sphere
of visibility around you.
And as we play tested, we
got a lot of good feedback
on what that visibility
means to people
and how we can
actually use it to make
our mechanics and our
[INAUDIBLE] design
more compelling.
Another big issue we
ran into with people
play testing was
our collision boxes
are basically pixel perfect.
And so people would
get caught trying
to go through the map, which
was really helpful for us,
because although we already
knew that this problem existed,
we actually learned a lot
about how people were actually
trying to make these decisions.
And we learned that
instead of using
the idea of the entire
[INAUDIBLE], a lot of players
were actually looking at
where the feet were planted
and trying to move
based on that.
So when we go and
fix it, we'll make
sure to put the collision box
around where the feet are.
We also got a lot of good
feedback on the items
that we have in our game and
where people are actually
focusing their attention.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Oh, Plunder Winds.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So our game
involves moving around a grid
and running into
random encounters.
The favorability of
the random encounters
are indicated to the player
by numbers and colors
on the board.
So one of the biggest things
that we got from testing
was that people
didn't understand
the role of the numbers
and colors played
or how they were related
or if they were related.
And they began by moving around
randomly and just waiting
for things to happen to them.
There's also a
mechanic in our game
that involves moving with the
wind and against the wind.
And so moving with the
wind doesn't count stamina,
but moving against
the wind does.
Or moving sideways
of the wind does.
Moving against the
wind is not possible.
People had trouble
figuring that out as well.
So one of the biggest things
we're going to try and do
is more visual
feedback to the player,
help them figure
things out as it goes.
Also, people felt
like there should
be more long-term consequences
instead of just planning
for the next move or two.
And so we're going to see
how we can integrate that
into our game.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Blind Aliens.
So we got a lot
of great feedback
from the use play testing.
So one of the main
things we realized
is we needed more clear goals
and more long-term goals.
So for example, our gun
automatically reloads,
and that was a little
confusing for people
because they didn't really
see that it was reloading.
But instead of doing
something like that
where the gun
automatically reloads,
we're thinking of adding
bullets around that you
have to go and collect so it's
more short-term goals and also
long-term strategy.
How do you save your bullets
up, when do you use them all.
Another thing we noticed
was that our game
was way too hard at
first, and way too
easy after five minutes.
So we decided we need to focus
on ramping up the difficulty.
Instead of starting with
three aliens attacking you,
maybe only one.
And then maybe after five
minutes, instead of only having
three aliens, maybe 10.
[INAUDIBLE] difficult.
So another thing we
focused on was our AI.
Not AI.
User interface.
So I talked about how there
was a reloading thing,
it was flashing in the
corner, but no one saw it
so no one knew that
their gun was reloading.
They thought it
just wasn't working
and they were frustrated
that they were clicking
and nothing was happening.
So we need to make
that more visual.
Along with our aliens,
when they're half-dead
or they're still attacking you.
People thought they were dead.
They'd run into them and
they'd die and be frustrated.
So instead of maybe
turning them darker,
maybe turn them red or something
like that to make that clearer.
So thank you guys
for all the feedback.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Modudice.
AUDIENCE: Hi, we're Modudice.
So a lot of the feedback we
got was really based on our UI.
And it's because we're modeling
a 3-D die using 2-D graphics.
So a lot of people
have different opinions
about how that should
look, and no one
thought that the way
it does look is OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
And so we really got
a lot of opinions.
Maybe you could do it this way.
And that really
helps, because now we
can really build up a discussion
of how it should look.
How we can make this mental
model in people's heads
match what they're seeing
on the screen, which
is the real hard challenge
that we're facing.
So thanks for the feedback.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: Beaver Evolution.
PHILIP TAN: I told them it
was going to be the problem,
someone needs to go up.
AUDIENCE: So through
play testing,
we really realized that we
weren't conveying to the user
exactly why all the
instructions worked clearly
and what was happening
at each turn.
But otherwise, the game
mechanics worked pretty well.
So in Beaver Evolution,
you can choose
whether to build,
populate, or evolve,
but it wasn't
clear to the player
exactly how many
beavers you can populate
or how many dams
you could build,
or what natural
disasters could happen.
And then between each turn, when
a natural disaster happened,
there wasn't that
much engagement
between the player and
the game being like,
oh, this drought
happened and then
this is a consequence of that.
So I think going forward,
we're going to really try
to make it easier for players
to understand what happened
during that turn, and then
what their choices are
in terms of picking it.
So a lot of it is clarifying
what the instructions are,
what the game mechanics are.
[APPLAUSE]
PROFESSOR: And
finally, Comcastic.
AUDIENCE: Well,
the two main pieces
of feedback that
we got from players
were about the UI of the game.
And we had some issues with
that because our game has
a lot of complex UI
requirements and we
didn't have time to implement
all of those prior to this test
session.
But we did get a lot of feedback
about UI improvements that
would make it easier
for players to see what
was going on with the game.
For example,
highlighting houses that
are currently being served
by a [? source ?] center.
The other main
complaint that we got
was that the game is
nebulous right now.
There's not a whole
lot of challenge
or clearly defined goal.
And so one thing
that we're really
going to look at
going forward is
tightening the focus of the
game, addling more tension,
and making the goal of
the game more concrete.
And since it doesn't fit very
well into an established genre,
we had some more
complex design decisions
to figure out how to make
this a fun and engaging game.
And so that's pretty
much what we're
going to be focusing
on going forward,
would be the UI and adding
more challenge and tension
to the game.
[APPLAUSE]
PHILIP TAN: I have a few words.
Do you have anything to say?
PROFESSOR: You go for it.
PHILIP TAN: OK.
So I just want to
remind everybody
that you started on this
project less than 10 days ago.
OK.
And you just finished your
first playable prototype,
and you did a good test.
So give yourself a hand.
[APPLAUSE]
Let's see.
Things to keep in mind.
For those of you who are
making mouse-driven games,
you want to make sure
that you have enough mice
to have for your next play test
which will be probably project
three.
And you've only got
another five days,
if I'm not mistaken,
when this is done.
This is exactly a
two week project.
So if you haven't
started cutting features,
this is probably
the time to do it.
Let's see.
Something that, of course,
we did notice and you all
felt it was that there weren't
enough stations for playing
the games.
For future play tests,
for project three onwards,
we are going to expect at least
half as many game computers
as you have at the
average team size.
So I'm not sure whether
we're doing with teams of six
or teams of eight.
We're doing teams of six
for project three, which
means each team
should be prepared
to have at least three computers
running with the games.
Something else that
we're also going
to make it a lot clearer
where the game stations are
is that the computers that are
not being used for game play
should actually just be closed.
Take notes using paper, because
it gets confusing to figure out
which are the game stations and
which ones are just like people
taking notes and which ones are
the ones where people actually
coding on the sly trying to
fix last minute problems.
You really should have all
that sorted out before the play
test, not during the play test.
So next time when
we're doing play test,
just make sure that half
your team, basically,
is ready to go with the game.
And I would suggest
more than half
your team should be able to
run the code, just in case
someone falls sick, right?
And doesn't bring their
computer or their mouse.
Rest of the class is for you
to work on your own team.
If anyone hasn't signed
into the attendance sheet,
we still have it up here.
And I want to have everyone
give the folks from Riot
a big hand for coming and
giving their feedback.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
GENEVIEVE CONLEY: [INAUDIBLE].
PHILIP TAN: Oh, yes.
They have lots of information
about internships.
Oops.
Oh, whoa.
A very, very large stack of
documents and positions that
are available.
And a deadline,
October 15th, which
is not that long from now.
So definitely check those
out as soon as you can.
Let's see.
Actually, while
we're on internships,
there's one other thing
that I wanted to mention.
I sent out a message for
Europe over in AeroAstro.
They are looking
for game developers.
Even better if you
also know MATLAB,
but they just want
game developers
for a high school
science competition
that they're running.
It's like first robotics.
It's a robotics competition,
only in zero gravity.
So if that sounds cool,
you should definitely
respond to them quickly because
Europe deadlines are coming up.
And that's it.
See you [INAUDIBLE].